hello everyone and welcome to our
science news webinar hi I'm Carolyn
Grambling and I am the earth and climate
writer for science news magazine and
with me today is Malin Pinsky who was
recognized this year in the magazines
scientists to watch issue Malin is a
marine ecologist at Rutgers University
where he investigates how climate change
is affecting fish populations in the
world's oceans
welcome to Malin thanks so much it's
wonderful to be here so manly can you
start by telling our viewers a little
bit about what your lab does yeah so my
research group studies broadly ecology
and evolutionary biology so we study the
interactions between different species
and so animals and plants and and other
species and the interactions with their
environment and we focus we focus in
particular on how climate change is
affecting fish crustaceans and other
animals in the ocean and you know some
of the key findings over the last few
years have been that marine animals are
especially sensitive to warming even
more sensitive in many cases than
animals on land I that marine species
like fish are rapidly moving to new new
locations as ocean temperatures warm and
also that these changes are rippling
throughout our society in many ways
they're affecting fishing behavior
they're affecting the food that shows up
on our plates they're even affecting
international trade and international
politics in some cases so as wonder if
you could maybe paint a little bit of a
picture for some of these fish
populations how they are actually
shifting around as as the ocean
temperatures warm where are some of them
going and you know how far they shifting
that sort of thing sure yeah I mean I
can actually put together so I put
together a couple maps that I will show
just to make that a little more concrete
in this particular map we're just
looking at the Northeast u.s. so we have
Canada up at the top got North Carolina
down here at the bottom New York City so
right here in in the middle
close to where Rutgers University is and
this this map is showing in red serve
areas with high biomass or high density
of a species called black sea bass it's
important fishery species both
commercially and recreationally there's
a map from the late 1970s and by 2018
they chipped it all the way north from
being sort of off Virginia to being off
Rhode Island and Massachusetts so it's
really dramatic changes in many cases
catch great question no the this is
actually data from a fall scientific
survey scientific survey that the
National Marine fishery service conducts
in the fall and we work in collaboration
with the National reading for service
and we put all of these maps actually up
online on a website called Ocean adapt
they've got the website over here on the
the right hand of the screen ocean adapt
on Rutgers tide edu it's not just black
sea bass it's more than 500 different
species not just in the Northeast US but
actually on nearly every coast around
the u.s. so lots of information provided
about where species are and also how
they've been moving these are animations
I've just showed you a couple clips from
that animation here so it's temperature
the only thing controlling these shifts
and if not what other what other factors
might be affecting large changes in
movement and behavior of fish so you
know temperature is one of the most
pervasive ones you know affecting a
really wide range of species all all
around the world all around the US but
there are other important ones
temperature actually interacts in really
important ways with oxygen one of the
other consequences of climate change has
been declining oxygen levels in the
ocean makes it harder in effect for
fishery for fish to and other marine
animals to breathe right and that
interacts with temperature because as
temperatures go up the metabolism goes
up their heart rate goes up and they
demand more oxygen so that's why oxygen
and and temperature interact in
important ways but even that is not the
only important one you know those are
those are two really big ones that
fisheries can be important where their
prey are found no for some earning
species like whales right they're not as
directly affected by temperature because
they're they're warm-blooded they're
endotherms but they're when their prey
move they often move with them and we've
seen that happen in Maine we've seen
that happen in California in other
places
one of the big findings that came out of
your labs work this past year they got a
lot of media attention is that the
sustainable catch of more than a hundred
different types of fish and shellfish is
getting smaller knows what if you could
talk a little bit about what sustainable
catch is and how you how your lab
determined that that is something that
is going to have to be reassessed right
so you know you know in sort of a basic
way that sustainable catch is when the
number of fish we take out in a year
from a given population is replenished
by the reproduction of that particular
population and when those two things are
balanced then the population won't
continue going down it also won't go up
but that's considered sustainable and it
ends up being you know a level that we
can determine based on observations of
how many fish there are in the ocean how
fast they grow and also how many fish
are being caught by fisheries so but
that particular research project we
looked at 235 different project
populations all around the world looked
at the population levels how fast those
populations were growing how many fish
were being taken out by fisheries and we
looked at the relationship between
population growth rates and the
temperature of the ocean water what we
found was that for some populations
warmer temperatures are good and
actually they grow faster but for many
other populations actually majority
warming temperatures are actually making
them making their populations grow more
slowly so it led globally actually to a
four percent drop already in sustainable
fisheries catch levels since 1930 and
that's really dramatic I mean doesn't
sound like a lot but it's really quite
dramatic let me think about how many
people rely on fish for food about one
in every two people alive today and also
just how globally traded
fish are they they're really integrated
into our coffee I want to follow up a
little bit on the ocean adapt and talk
about some of the work that you've been
doing with fisheries managers and
governments to try and figure out what
you know what is sustainable to do a as
you call it a fish forecast like a
weather forecast for fish so yeah can
you sort of explain what what how you
can work with them and what what sort of
what is a fish forecast that's it's
something we're actively working on
right now upon adapt we have not only
maps of where species have been but also
maps of where we're projecting species
are likely to be over the coming decades
right now these are in 20-year junks but
one of the things we've heard from
fisheries managers is that they really
want nearer term information they're
curious where are these species likely
to be next year over the next or maybe
the next few years five years ten years
so we're actively trying to put together
near-term sort of year by year fish
forecast because that's what we've heard
would be more useful so we work quite a
bit with fisheries managers with at the
federal level the National Marine
Fisheries Service but also at a regional
level a lot of the Fisheries regulations
in the US are made by regional fisheries
management councils they're groups of
fishers other stakeholders conservation
groups government representatives and
they really come together and make many
of the hard decisions and we try to work
with them to provide some of the
information they need about where fish
are where they're moving so that they
can I set regulations that were more
most likely to meet those sustainable
catch levels I wanted to sort of mention
that your work has been incorporated
into a major climate international
climate report that came out just about
a month ago or so one of the
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
change's reports this one focusing on
the cryosphere in oceans and I guess I
would love for you to give a little
perspective on like how how does your
work fit into this bigger picture of you
know how climate change has affected the
oceans and you know what is the
significance of having an ocean focused
climate report in that way it is
incredibly significant you know
just ten years ago nearly all of the
research on climate change impacts on
species was focused on terrestrial
species species online and what we've
learned in those last 10 years is that
actually some of the most dramatic
impacts know them fastest ships and
species distributions the most sensitive
species in many cases from a
physiological perspective are actually
in the ocean so this report that's come
out no I think is just marks a really
important turning point and serve the
global understanding of how climate
change impacts are playing out and
there's also really important for help
helping move scientific information into
the policy process could sorry about
one-stop-shop for understanding the
scale what's happening and what some of
the potential solutions are I was going
to sort of move to solutions because
that's something I think a lot of people
really want to talk about and hear about
but in your opinion what is you know you
said that one of your labs goals is to
shape more thoughtful ocean policy what
would that look like what is it more
thoughtful ocean policy yeah you know
there are a few key areas on the policy
side we can talk maybe a little bit
later about what can be done at a local
at a local lever level or by individuals
but sustainable fisheries management and
trying to understand how those
sustainable catch levels change as
climate changes is one incredibly
important area one of the other key
things we're finding is that as fish
move when they move across political
boundaries right they don't care about
the local boundaries those are just
imaginary lines basically that we as
humans draw on the ocean but when they
cross political boundaries they often
cause conflict right they open these new
debates about should the people who
historically had access to the fish
still have access or should the people
who are closest to the fish now now have
accidents and sometimes caused in some
cases like mackerel and Iceland it's
even caused initiated trade Wars and
other international conflicts so you
know one of the things we've I
we you know I think we really need is
better coordination and cooperation
across national boundaries around
fisheries management and largely they're
not entirely within a nation effort are
there are there signs at this point that
people might be trying to make this this
kind of a cross boundary cooperative
movements are records you know
definitely I mean there are you know we
already have these regional fisheries
management organizations not to be
confused with sort of the what's happens
within regions in the US but actually
across country yeah they're across
countries under the Food and Agriculture
Organization they're starting to address
some of these issues
I think they some of the countries
participating in those organizations
would like to address these issues more
some would not so it becomes something
of a tension and I one of the things I
hope is that making the impacts and the
changes that are already occurring very
clear and hard to ignore we can help
motivate some more response on the
policy side as well I just want to take
a moment to remind our viewers that at
this point if you have questions for
mailing that you want to ask please use
the Q&A function at the bottom of your
screen to type them in and I will try to
get to as many of those questions as we
possibly can we actually have a reader
question that's sort of a nice follow-on
to what you were just saying and this
reader wanted to know if they if you
know of any new or pending international
laws or regulations that might actually
aid in the goal of having this kind of
cross boundary things like a you know
more comprehensive law of the sea or an
oceanic Paris Accord or anything of that
nature yeah no there's actually ongoing
discussions right now under the United
Nations about a new treaty for the high
seas the law of the sea largely the
existing law to see unbidden I know
nations largely governs and happens
within national waters leaving the high
seas or at these large areas of the
ocean there
outside 200 nautical miles from the
coast more of the Wild West right now
biodiversity conservation really hasn't
received anywhere near as much attention
right now so there are efforts ongoing
to figure out where should we set up
protected areas in the high seas and
what should be the standards and the
sustainable levels of human impact in
the high seas that all countries can
agree on so those negotiations actually
are I'm doing right now I think I hope
will be very productive is this
something that's going to be discussed
in in Chile as far as you're aware that
the next UN Ocean policy heard the cop
meeting which I think Julie's president
is calling the blue cop yeah I don't
know it's a it's a separate process so I
don't know specifically yeah yeah I mean
there also is just a new report that
came out there's from the United Nations
high-level panel on the ocean economy
talking about ocean solutions you know
how important human activities in the
ocean can be for mitigating climate
change both both for capturing carbon
but also just from removes or removing
emissions from reducing emissions from
activities like fishing or shipping or
aquaculture so as a way to counteract
yeah exactly so that that report is very
directly relevant to the we do have a
reader question who want to ask about
ocean acidification here let me just
call this up one of the current effects
of ocean acidification on marine life
and can you explain how global warming
might be acidifying the oceans yeah no
it's really important and often I
underappreciated impact in part because
it's somewhat unique to the ocean right
it doesn't affect terrestrial species
not in the same way but as carbon
dioxide concentrations increase in the
atmosphere some of that carbon dioxide
about a quarter of actually the excess
carbon dioxide has been absorbed into
the ocean and that sets off a series of
chemical reactions hydrogen ion
concentrations go up so that
that's what makes eh go down that's what
makes the ocean more acidic I Hydra ion
concentrations have actually gone up by
about 30 percent since the beginning of
the Industrial Revolution but then the
chemical reactions sort of continuing
cascade carbonate ion concentrations go
down those are incredibly important for
corals to build their skeletons clams to
build their build their shells as well
as a wide range of other species that
build shells so it makes it more
difficult for many many marine species
to build either their skeletons for or
their shells species like fish are a
little bit less directly impacted but
they are definitely impacted by changes
in their prey and also impacts is
actually impacts actually their sensory
abilities change affects their sense of
hearing their sense of smell it's a
really pervasive does that make people
to be preyed upon as well many of the
experiments suggest that it does yeah
another reader wants to know about ocean
temperatures how they are measured in
the oceans you know how in what
locations they're measured and what sort
of depths yeah and it's a great question
there's a a global network of ocean
temperature observations and it takes
many different forms from really basic
technology like sticking a bucket over
the side of a boat and sticking a
thermometer in it which is you know been
going on for that's been going on for
hundreds of years and it actually really
valuable as a long-term record to large
moment nearly global measurements of
ocean surface temperature from
satellites you know it's something that
can be seen from space problem being
that it's really just just the surface
so there I especially over the last
couple decades a network of what are
called Argo floats there are these
really cool buoys that float around in
the ocean and they sink down to in some
cases very deep depths in the ocean
recording temperature and other
measurements in the ocean as they go
come back up transmit their results to a
satellite and then are available to
scientists and everyone else all around
the world and then keep going so there
are many other technologies as well
beyond that but those are some of the
big ones you mentioned how we have a
much longer record of course of surface
open ocean temperatures a much more
complete record so another reader has
asked are the deep oceans as affected by
warming and as on the surface yeah so
the impacts of warming now or being seen
even all the way down to the the bottom
of the ocean the amount of warming is
quite a bit less right the heat is
coming in from the surface and slowly
being carried down to the depths but
even at depth it's high the warming is
being seen it's a little bit harder to
detect our records aren't as goodness
obviously a lot harder to measure
temperature at the bottom of the ocean
the records don't go back as far they're
not as global they're more in specific
places so but yes the morning throughout
them yeah exactly and it's also you know
you know we have to think about now may
not be warming as much but also it's an
environment that has a extremely
constant temperature just because it's
so isolated from the atmosphere so even
a little bit it's a lot compared to what
species are used to and also the animals
and the other organisms that live down
there they rely on the food that filters
down from above and that food is very
directly being affected by changing
ocean conditions that actually segues
nicely to another reader question that I
had which is you had mentioned earlier
that the growth rates for many species
are slower due to warmer ocean
temperatures and this reading was asking
is this a direct result of the warming
or is it due to food availability or
changes in food available availability
yeah it's a really good question and
still an active area of research right
now there are good reasons to think from
a physiological perspective
fish are very directly affected by
temperature basically their metabolism
goes up their heart rate goes up when
temperature goes up but the rate
which they can pull oxygen out of the
water I is pretty limited actually and
they relatively quickly hit that limit
where their metabolism demands a lot of
oxygen but they can't pull it out of the
water fast enough so that's a direct
temperature effect oh you're right um
you know prey or being affected food
availability is being affected and that
also has very important impacts on many
fish populations and the impacts were
observing are probably a combination of
both
you
you
faster Pearson so this reader wants to
know was there anything about the IPCC
oceans and credits cryosphere report
that surprised you or was it you know
information that we already pretty much
knew no I think you know even though I'm
sort of embedded in this world and this
is a lot of what I study from day to day
I was just surprised at how pervasive
the effects have already been how much
certainty there already is about the
changes that are happening and how
certain we are about the changes were in
for you know I think some of the really
dramatic impacts also have to do with
sea level rise you know it's not just
fish on the move but also at the level
of the ocean coming up already up by no
six inches high and that increases
erosion that increases flooding you know
I've seen news reports that parts of the
Florida Keys have been flooded for the
last four parts the last forty days so
you know it's really affecting coastal
communities very dramatically yeah yeah
so what another reader wants to ask
about the coasts how climate change
might be affecting coastal vegetation as
well as vegetation the ocean perhaps
kelp forests yeah there are sort of two
- impacts of climate change on kelp one
one has to do with warmer waters in many
cases have fewer nutrients so from the
perspective
Oh kelp makes it harder for them to grow
makes them more susceptible to swamped
by storms and the other thing that's
happen in some places you know really
dramatically actually on the coast of
Australia on down internet Tasmania is
that I some of the more warm water or
preferring sea urchins that eat kelp
have been moving towards higher
latitudes and I've just basic mode down
kelp forests and just you know it's a
really quick transition for some of
these ecosystems and obviously kelp are
really important for a wide range of
other species many fish shelter in kelp
many young marine animals rely on kelp
as basically their nurseries and it's
also kelp forests are supposed to be a
possible location for sequestering
carbon as well yeah I mean kelp do grow
very fast they can suck up a lot of
carbon very quickly important question
though it was where that kelp goes after
it's basically pulled into the kelp
blade and stalk you know if it just gets
sort of washed offshore eaten by
bacteria and that carbon dioxide then
goes back into the atmosphere then yeah
it's definitely a long-term sunix yeah
yeah there's been more discussion about
seagrass beds No
see dress when they when they die they
often actually get buried under many
layers of sand and they're actually the
carbon is sequestered as well as marshes
you know there's very low oxygen mud in
in marshes where carbon can gets quested
and doesn't decompose I want to get to a
question that I think is a really one
that a lot of people are wondering which
is this comes from a reader who says he
teaches a or she teaches a marine
biology course many of my students feel
they are only one person and the changes
they make are too insignificant to make
a difference what would you say to these
students what are some of the more
impactful changes they can make to help
preserve the oceans and biodiversity ya
know it's a it's a great question and
you know I think you know in in terms of
helping conserve the ocean and all
efforts are going to start local and
they're going to start a small community
often with one per person who's
dedicated and can inspire those people
around them I think that's that's so
important two of the biggest threats to
the ocean right now are overfishing and
climate change and there's a lot that an
individual can do overfishing I work
consumers of seafood so we can choose to
buy sustainable sources of seafood
there's a marine stewardship label you
can often find it in the supermarket or
use something like the Monterey Bay
Aquarium Seafood Watch
app to choose sustainable make
sustainable seafood choices and if you
know restaurants and supermarkets aren't
carrying it locally you can ask you know
and try to try to make that change
locally I think the other key thing is
you know trying to reduce our impact on
the climate in terms of biking more
using public transportation more and
also just making that easier within our
communities bike paths making public
transportation more convenient you can
also choose renewable sources of
electricity for school buildings for
town buildings for our houses that's
something my wife and I have decided to
do as well so thanks a lot we can do I
have a question from mrs. Peter Coward's
I hope I'm pronouncing that correctly 6
. AP environmental science class and
they want to know
hi they want to know which regions of
the world are most affected I I don't
know if I can I'm guessing the question
is about climate change in particular
yeah perhaps temperature in the oceans
or acidification or yeah ocean changes
yeah
the so we're seeing very dramatic
changes in in the surface of the ocean
right now most of the observations are
from the coastal ocean in part that's
because we're that's where we are the
most where we interact with them the
most so I don't know if I can point to
one specific place in general other than
the tropics you know it's where species
marine species live closest to the upper
temperatures that they can tolerate it's
where coral reefs are really important
source of shelter and food for thousands
of marine species and they are also very
as we've seen in the news very sensitive
to warming temperatures with this
process of now nearly global coral coral
reef bleaching I have a reader who wants
to know why you decided to focus on how
climate change is affecting ocean life
specifically know it was a an area of
research that I came into in parks I
felt like I there was so much attention
to what was happening on on land and I
was really curious about whether similar
impacts were happening in the ocean and
it also seemed like an area that if we
had our information on that it could be
very very important and very useful for
informing public policy I mean I'm I'm
inspired to do science now not only by
my curiosity and the chance to be
creative and dive into challenging
problems and getting I you know diving
deep into them but also to provide
science and new knowledge that can be
can be useful to society so that was
part of the inspiration in the
motivation and two years do you yourself
have a favorite fish
I have to say I think it would be an
anemone fish some of the research I do
is actually on an M&E fish you know the
cute black white and orange species that
live on coral reefs they are very
charismatic yes yes there Nemo this
reader was asking that as far as what is
your favorite to study or to look at her
to admire as opposed to eat oh yeah no I
have not ever eaten a clownfish let's
see oh here's a great question how do
you balance the big idea with a nearly
endless accumulation of specific data
how do you keep how do you pulled I
guess big ideas out of that data or yeah
you know I think it's one of the really
fun challenges about science right we
have to get the details right but it's
not going to be relevant unless we can
see the big picture and how it fits into
the larger context so it's sort of this
back-and-forth process of digging down
into the technical details and then
stepping back to understand what does
this mean and you know there what does
it mean can be thought about in
different ways you know what does it
mean for scientific knowledge you know
how is it impact other researchers but
you know have you been more importantly
what does this mean for society was this
need for public policy okay if just
reminder I think we're about drawing to
a conclusion here but if there's any
last questions anyone would like to
shoot through the Q&A chat function
please let me know otherwise I just
would like to say a huge thank you to
Mei Lin for tuning in and answering all
of our questions and giving us so much
great information about the future of
fish and what we should how we can try
and contribute to sustainability so
thank you so much Mei Lin for for your
time and thank you everyone for tuning
in thanks so much Carolyn and thanks
everyone for tuning in for your interest